the teachers in Oklahoma could be the
next to go and strike over low wages
educators in the state are the second
lowest paid in the US on average they
make just over $45,000 a year
yesterday West Virginia teachers
celebrated as they're nine days strike
ended the governor signed a bill for a
5% pay raise
Omar Villafranca is inside white rock
school in Lincoln County Oklahoma with
how many of that state schools switched
to a four-day work week to make up for
low pay Omar good morning good morning
the White Rock school moved to afford a
schedule in 2016 to save money now they
weren't able to save that much but they
did notice that there were more
experienced teachers applying for jobs
here we also went to another school
district that moved to the four-day week
and they're selling that to teachers as
a job perk tax features jillaine watham
teaches second grade at Bridge Creek
public school outside of Oklahoma City
although teachers in her state makes
some of the lowest wages in the country
she loves working a shortened four-day
school weeks how was your quality of
life changed it has allowed that weekend
time with my family but I also really
truly feel like it has made me a better
teacher by being purposeful and looking
at time management 210 of the state
schools operate on a four-day scheduled
many stay-at-home parents we spoke to in
this community endorsed the shortened
week it's just that extra day you're
like I feel like I have a whole entire
day with my kid we should not encourage
this but state superintendent of
instruction joy Hofmeister worries about
the long term impact on students
Oklahoma's public school system requires
students to attend at least 180 days or
1080 hours of school a year shortened
weeks mean longer days from 40 minutes
to an hour more in some cases we are
losing valuable time to sustain momentum
and grow just extending more minutes to
the day is not actually the same as
having more days in the calendar year
you came in when funding was in the
middle of
correct Bridge Creek superintendent
David Moro says his district cut down
the school week to recruit teachers in
2016 amid a statewide teacher shortage
due to low pay can you get better
teachers with that four-day school week
several years ago we were on the five
day school week and I had three three
openings at our elementary school and
had four applicants same three openings
now and you have 15 to 20 applicants the
average teaching salary in Oklahoma is
the lowest of its neighbors teachers in
nearby Texas make nearly seven thousand
dollars more following recent strikes in
West Virginia Oklahoma teachers are now
debating a strike of their own are you
ready for a possible walkout on April
2nd that will be the most difficult
decision I had ever made you haven't
made that decision yet I in my head
can't imagine not being here
teacher organizations plan to announce a
possible walkout date soon and one of
the dates they are throwing around is
April 2nd that's important because that
is the first day of state testing in
Oklahoma teachers are asking the
legislature for a $10,000 raise over the
next three years Gale that dates very
strategic thank you very much Omar
thanks a lot